[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i want winners 30 to one you hit it you
called it on the show
i'm happy my bank account's happening
i'm giving away hoodies all show you're
getting a hoodie for that you get a
hoodie
all three of you get hoodies mikey how
many money have you given out today like
45
i'm not counting who knows it's time
we're all going in together
we have somebody here who likes to face
the group chat you guys are the
absolute worst put some bleeping respect
on my name
why are you even in this group chat
you're not even betting and now you're
gonna tell me i'm wrong you have no
original takes get him out again i don't
want you in here get out of the group
chat
[Music]
goodbye
you just joined the vr betting group
chat let's go
we've got locks we've got hoodies we've
got
game four of the nba finals happening in
my hair looks full so i'm having a nice
hair day i'm glad you're here for it
i am burned alongside kelly and vegas
greg ivory it looks full
mikey locks maybe mikey fraud and cabbie
richards
we're giving away hoodies all show so
keep firing off your takes in the
comments
first tonight we have game four of the
nba final
the lakers lead the series 2-1 over
miami
and they are heavily favored to win this
game
so who do we think is winning finals mvp
we asked last week
is this changing at all greg you had one
of the craziest picks i've ever seen
are you standing by what do you mean
what do you mean
by it of course of course i don't even
know why his name
isn't on this graphic man there's a
producer right here
what are the producers doing his name
needs to be on this graphic
yes i'm talking about andre iguodala
listen to me
he's shooting over 50 percent on the
series i want you guys to know that
before you guys make your takes okay
it's game four of the series it's game
four of the series
he has time to make a stamp guys
he has time to make a stamp we're
talking about a former i haven't
ever heard of in my life somebody cherry
pick a stat like that saying my dude is
fifty percent with these two
one relax that's that's fifty percent
that's fifty percent he scored two
points in his last game greg what are
you talking about dude again
hey did they win cabbie did they win
yeah
because he contributed 17 minutes off
the bench
contribution there that's what i'm
talking about andre iguodala
is likely a hall of famer he's a
three-time champion he will not be a
four-time champion
and he will definitely not win finals of
epg money come on dude
you know the finals mvp is going to be
given to the star of train wreck
and to the star of space jam 2. there's
still time for the animators
to animate in his four finals mvp
that's what i was thinking i was like
wait amy schumer bill
guys amy schumer is not in space jam too
unless she's one of the monsters she
could be which is entirely
she might be she's well listen they're
gonna put lebron's
finals mvp trophies in his
in his holster they could you can fire
them out look okay
real talk lebron is averaging 28 points
11 rebounds and nine assists in the
finals
those are better numbers than he had in
2016
when he won the finals mvp and this is
the lakers are gonna wrap it up in five
games put a nice bow on it and then
present to the world
a perfect hollywood ending lebron for
mvp
it's written in stone i'm seeing a
little there's no value there there was
value when you listened to me at minus
160 before but it's gonna happen mikey
locks but it's not worth betting right
now how is that worth betting right now
what's worth betting right now
winning winning is worth betting jim
butler up to 950 keep our plus 900 to
win the series
if he win the series jim butler will win
mpt no doubt you're getting 50 cents of
value
you're going to value town on that kelly
can you check me on that i like ad2 at
three to one
if he just goes off for a 50 night which
he can easily do
i think his odds jump a lot burn don't
show me ellie it's kelly
no no no no all you
[Music]
i hate that i'm in locks up with mikey i
would love
to bet jimmy butler here uh plus 950 but
i don't think the heat are going to be
able to pull this out
thus i don't think he's going to win in
vp i do think anthony davis the best
player on the court for both teams
is going to win mvp at three to one my
dude has absolutely taken over he even
said it the other day in ig
we just got to let lebron think he's the
best player he's going to
feed my dude the ball the assist king
gives the eyebrows the opportunity
to make the plays he's going to win mvp
when the lakers win this series
hold on cows at the most it will be
co-mvps and that's
never happened before jerry west once
won
a finals mvp on the losing side i think
in 1969
but it but this would be unprecedented
as working any of you guys remember 1969
i think it's been a long time it's like
the same as the last time i'm running
back
one mvp it's not gonna happen
adrian peterson did that in 2012 and in
1969 they landed on the moon but anyway
it will be a co-mvp but did they cabbie
[Laughter]
mikey another show for another time
mikey did you just comment on my hair
yeah i said 1969 was like the time you
had hair
was that good will you take your hat off
will you take your hat off so we can see
what's happening under there
you're talking about yeah mike why do
you always wear a hat call out vern you
better
step up please take your hat off please
take your hat off
i shave my mustache i'll hop up yeah we
need a haircut
oh my goodness okay wow are you
those are good vibes bro you look like
it is right
junior rhode island i'm taking anthony
davis i took him before this series
started on only one
i'm clearly a guru you should all you
change your picks for this entire show
and just ride with me
80 three to one okay before you guys can
disagree
greg i know the people in the comments
are with me what are you seeing
yeah they're all over me in the comments
i'm not gonna lie
m tuck is rocking with me though so he's
getting a hoodie he's asking the
producers
um producer max where's iggy need him on
the graphic
so just because of that m tuck you're
walking away with a hoodie uh
my guy danny barry bond i guess is
that's his name he said dude is high on
something i'm assuming that he's talking
to me being high on something
yes actually i am high on something i'm
high on giving you a hoodie brother
so you're walking away with a hoodie uh
here we go i think
the comments we're getting a lot of uh
unltdj said greg enjoying that henny i
see
i'm at my parents house we can't be too
loud but yes yes yes i do
i do enjoy the hoodie um i see a lot of
i see a lot of ad pics they're rocking
with you guys uh
vern and kelly the fans is rocking with
you i'm seeing a lot of ad pics
rocking with you oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm sorry
i can and i will watch me ridiculous all
right all right
moving on we posted this ticket on
social
from at labe the babe or
at la b the baby he hid an exact
win margin at 95 to one
on fanduel he bet what did it do
[Music]
we all want some of that magic who are
we taking the win game for
and by what market all right you look
there there's some huge payouts there's
some big ones
especially if you're on the heat greg
you like the heat to win this game don't
you
of course i want the heat i like the
heat to win this game um i see this
this series actually going seven but i
think this game tonight is gonna be a
close one it's gonna be close towards
the end heat might be up
one two uh one or two points but i think
uh it's gonna be late foul trouble
so the heat are gonna win by i'd say
three points in this one heat by three
because of late foul trouble with the
lakers
yeah greg listen i i agree with you i do
think this game is
is gonna go late it's gonna be decided
by late free throws i went back and
forth on this i don't think la's gonna
cover i think the spread is
too high um i'm gonna call it lakers by
six this is not an
easy guess that's how come that dude
just got paid on his ticket
now i'm like you guys throwing darts it
couldn't
i think everyone wins but doesn't cover
i want to one-up you on this dartboard
vern i have a little homework assignment
for you to get back
to my good graces because we're not
vibey right now i think we need to make
a
fake roulette board okay
i love roulette i got a fake
relationship like we saw on our
social media oh yeah that was a roulette
board and then we're just sprinkling
chips all over the board lakers by six
miami by three
i like miami by one tonight i will be
putting a chip there
and we'll just let the chips fall where
they may i know you love roulette
let them fall mike you're talking about
mike you are talking my lane
guys guys listen anthony davis had like
the second worst game in the playoffs in
game three
my guy's coming out on fire to start the
first quarter
and lebron is not gonna let this slip
away it's just not in the cards
for that man he's gonna put his team on
his back the lakers are going to come
out
and put in work establish themselves as
the dominant team
right away and look we know batman obama
is going to be playing in game four but
is he 100 healthy or is he like
71 healthy and can they get him into
foul
trouble it doesn't matter lakers by not
i'm saying lakers gonna be big
they're gonna cover the spread in game
four
and just put that right boom in the hoop
abby i am with you
and look i just want a little bit
because this is such a dark throw this
is such a roulette spin
mikey if you will i'm taking the lakers
by
13. it's bigger value i'm ignoring the
heat because i don't think they're to
win
so i'm just taking that side of bets out
of the equation
going for a little bit more bang for my
buck lakers
by 13. shout out at i like lay bait the
babe
what'd it do baby i like that you and i
vernon we're aligned here it's like me
and andy sandberg's cousin randy
sandberg i like it
yeah we got kelly with us too she's not
far off greg are the comments with us
are they against us
the comments are all over the place i
got uh
cheap grace seven saying shaking my head
nah
lebron was pissed last game they woke
the beast
lakers by eight just because uh
just because of that cheap grace i'm
gonna give you a hoodie why not
um i got eric gonzo 90 sand lake show by
11. he's he's up there with you with you
and vern uh
cabbie i'm gonna get late i'm gonna give
ericanzo a hoodie
um anything is possible heat by five
with some late free throws yes
khloe khloe zero three two
three yes i like that take anything is
possible i'm gonna give you a hoodie i
got one more vern
i got one more for you greg your takes
are bad lakers in five
beds are mediocre guess what
just for my takes being bad you're not
getting a hoodie brother
you're not getting a hoodie back to you
love
burn
all right that was great we all know
jimmy butler was great too he had a 40
point triple double in game three
yesterday we threw it up on social and
in the bleach report
app we asked how many points will jimmy
butler score in game four tonight
we are giving away hoodies so check out
our post
but now i want to talk about someone who
is not happy with butler's big game
we've been showing you a lot of winning
same game parlay tickets on the show
but this week we are talking about our
guy
at little k-b-i-g-o or little k
b go who almost hit it big he went eight
for nine
oh this was so close not available
and a half points in game three is there
anything worse than losing a nine leg
parlay
on that kind of career performance kelly
i'm just gonna go ahead and say this
vern
i know our friends over at fanduel don't
want me to say this but
why are you betting 19 parlays why would
you not want that
that's the whole fun i hope he's out
there taking another one tonight keep it
rolling and eight out of nine let's go
she wanted eight out of nine kelly don't
you want a yacht gotta roll the dice
and maybe can you imagine how much money
he would have won if he bet those all
straight
not as much how much money would have
won and now it's
and now we hear all the crickets oh okay
my fault anyway
the bankroll was only 10 bucks so we'd
have to do like one dollar
or like a dollar fifty bets on them i'm
trying to buy you out of the nine that
hit
we i want a yacht you gotta roll the
dice ego wants a yacht
we all hate a bad beat we all feel for
you even kelly i promise
so at a little time i definitely feel
for him we are going to
send you a hoodie and we spoke to our
friends at fanduel
aka my friends at vandal cause i got the
hookup they hate mikey they love me
and they're gonna put 50 bucks in your
account so you're taking it home five to
one on your money
wait what he's getting 50 bucks just
because he
lost he wouldn't even
get bugs i guess i need to get me a fan
vern are you really the plug or are you
capping
no no no i'm the plug kaepernick all he
does is cap on this entire show
it's unreal kelly if you want that you
got to be just a little nicer to me
we can hook it up one day look if you
think
you have a worse beat than this send it
in to us
at br betting and by us i mean me
definitely not mikeylox anyone but mikey
locks maybe cabbie maybe kelly maybe
greg
anyone else yeah don't dm me okay cabbie
or greg
they got the hook up for fandol we'll
try to help you out
now let's build our own game four same
game parlay
we gotta ride it together if there's no
game seven
this is our last one of the season it
has to hit we gotta let the audience
decide
who's ruining the the parlay we will
kick you out
if you've ruined the parlay kick you out
of the parlay greg
take it away so we can we can let the
people you you got to be in the comments
with the people later
all right guys i got you here
on my leg of the parlay we're going to
rock with braun
over nine and a half rebounds here i see
brian coming out
a little more uh a little more pep in
his step
in this game than last game i know he
wants to close it
out and get his fourth ring but i don't
think that's gonna happen
but i do think that he's gonna go out
and be a little more assertive today
uh he's gonna have a little pep in his
step and he's gonna probably end up with
a triple double so i'm
rocking with the over nine and a half
rebounds like that
tonight i like that i like it now i know
that everybody expects a little
regression from this man but i do not
i think jimmy butler is gonna go for his
point total tonight he is the best heat
player
he's gonna have to step up as a leader
on that team and
drop his namesake and beat jimmy buckets
i like jimmy butler over 25 and a half
points
hey i like jimmy butler to go off too no
no no i love you guys go ahead lux
i love him to go off for over 25 and a
half kelly that's a great bet but the
other one on my
at plus money on fanduel him to hit one
three-pointer all he has to do is make
one three-pointer over zero five
three-pointers made that easy it's very
easy
in fact and i think he will do it this
is my second favorite bet of the night
stay tuned for my hammer lock coming at
the end of the show that's what we call
a tease in the biz vern
wade box miami has built that team of
so he has shooters around him to take
those three-point shots olynyk tyler
hero duncan robinson and jay crowder
jimmy buckets doesn't shoot
three-pointers my g why are you why are
you even selecting that he's he's shot
one in
in almost every game besides the last
game shot clock running down maybe he
gets a switch on a big he's always got
the ball in his hands
greg what do we say a little heavy heavy
queen tween step back
one crazy queen plea
that's not in jimmy buckets games listen
anthony davis is gonna assert himself
right from the jump he had a terrible
game not a tear but he had a subpar
game three and he's gonna look to just
be on fire in game four
right from the jump in twice against
denver
and once in this series he's had 14
points 14 points and 11 points in the
first quarter i'm going over
10 and a half points and vern shout out
to your homies at fanduel if you go deep
in the player props
you can find some gems and this is a gem
anthony davis
over ten and a half points in the first
q i want that action
immediately what kind of juice is on can
i get a little bowl though
yeah yeah that's plus 235 that's what
i'm saying
let's go i think that's selfish that
you're putting this in the parlay we
just need green checks next to all these
bets
we don't need any red marks
yeah i'm trying to win it y'all i wanna
make the pot even juicier at plus 235
with this part of the parlay
mikey that shannon davis is gonna be on
fire absolutely i'm with you cabbie
i got one i got one that i like for two
reasons
rajon rondo under nine and a half points
reason number one
because in the majority of his games
this postseason he's been under that
number
makes sense number two it's gonna be fun
to scream when he's shooting wide open
threes
so i'm also adding it in for the fun
factor
finally all right finally a rare w for
you and a rare good take i'm proud of
you that last take
you're gonna yell when you should eat
threes that's fine i'm proud of you we
might be back
we've been there hashtag burn logic
greg tell us which one of these bets is
gonna mess up the parlay
what are the people saying in the
comments who's getting the food
the people are in the comments loving
the hesi hesi tween
tween step back i'ma work on that move
coco9 said that
shout out to you you're getting a hoodie
uh they're not
rocking with cabbie i got m tuck again
saying get cabbie out of here
has he has he tween tween uh
bro and my guy clipped twice clip twice
says greg knows
how braun do he's been flirting with and
tickling the triple double every single
game
and that's an easy lock uh you're gonna
walk away with hoodie clip twice because
i think the same thing
but uh they want to get cabbie out of
here because uh i'm carrying
you're you're trying to throw a dart
that's just not
like no it's landing
anthony davis's turn around jay his step
back jay his baseline jay
he's going to get a couple of easy
alley-oops at the bucket and then we
wait guys can we get cabbie out
what's going on here this is ridiculous
i'm spitting on fire
the comments the comments wanted cabbie
out of here they say cabbie is messing
it up
gabby i thought they were like gabby was
their favorite i could have swore
maybe not this is it not kelly you're
actually getting some love today
that's right that is shocking greg give
those people
anything nice about me craig bay legend
geek the geek
who's in there who's in the comments uh
you know d
you know d geek is in here we should
just give him another hoodie he probably
has like 10 of them
uh okay i got d geek who would predict
mikey's hammer lock i guess they want
your hammerlock mikey uh
i've got it's come on no you're gonna
give it to him again that's a tease burn
this segment okay
you we're industry people we get it oh i
got one i i
got one vern before we move on this
one's super funny vern has
his hair all on one side to show he is
one side biased
who is that mets medicine
they wanted to make sure you hurt that
bird
[Laughter]
i well look i heard it that's funny
it's look it's just natural that's how
it goes are you going to give our dude a
hoodie great
he is ours mediocre he has he's another
one that has like 10 of them he
gets our humor all right real quick
we're recapping this overlay
greg's on lebron over nine and a half
rebounds
kelly's got jimmy butler points over
mikey has a three from jimmy butler
cabbie see you later he's not here i've
got rondo
under nine and a half points ah this is
hitting
this is it this is our moment we're
getting our yacht let's bring cabbie
back
in so we can share the glory it's all
right
and then we'll we'll move on hey cabbie
look we gotta really
oh hey gabby you want to talk about it
captain you look upset
about it i'm emotional you guys know i'm
emotional and i don't want to say
anything that's going to get me fired
i'm going to take the my cousin from
this slide let's go
no no i'm going to take my comments from
this group chat to this group chat
as soon as we're done okay all right
there's nothing better than when the
group chat bird knows
you know there's nothing better than
when the group chat just turns very very
personal
when a bet loses and then you just start
attacking another person in the group
chat
you say things you probably shouldn't
that's that seems to be where we're
heading and i can't wait it's great
content
it is good content and it's really funny
because cabbie's the nicest person on
here
when he gets mad you know it's serious
big fat this is also serious though
we've got to do some fast action quick
hitter first
quarter bets those are our favorite so
what should
our game four quick hitter be please
help us decide
drop them in the comments here are some
of our favorite type of quick hitter
bets
mikey you want that first quarter tie
it's plus 1600 i was looking at it
earlier
on
yeah like i might just start sprinkling
all over no i mean i didn't get kind of
now that never said it i didn't see it
before
now i really like it burn you know what
else i really like i teased a hammerlock
i teased it all show we are ready i'm
not going to give you
my yeah we're going into full hammer
lock mode i'm not going to give you
minus
you know 250 on a hammer lock minus 170.
we're taking
921. dwight howard furboo
first bucket furboo guru that's me your
boy
mikey locks mr right now when i get hot
i get hot and i'm telling you
dwight first bucket nine to one book it
i'm on your team for this mikey locks
with or without the henny i got the
lakers tenney race to 10.
miami got it in the first game lakers
second game miami third game
lakers tonight in game four first to ten
book that whoa whoa whoa whoa
cabbie we just kicked you out i love you
and i don't want to kick you out again
but i am fading you i am rocking with
the heat here
heat first you're losing heat first to
10.
i mean they're gonna get off to a fast
start
i see them winning this game so i'm
rocking with the heat the lakers are
known for that
getting off to that slow start so i see
i see the heat coming out
hot here just uh i'm rocking with the
heat
i'm working with the heat blow your
money away i lost for my i'm going to
talk into the wind
i'm rocking all right well i i don't
know i'm not very good at this race to
10 thing i understand cabbie
looks into it he always has his numbers
behind it but this back and forth thing
is just
there's no value there for me uh mikey
no why are we trying to overcomplicate
this heat first
quarter the heat are gonna come out hot
they're going to
take what happened in last game and
absolutely run with it i'm getting two
and a half
in the first quarter though that tie is
really interesting i'd have to look at
what the true odds should be it should
probably be closer to probably 25 to one
but it might be worth a sprinkle one of
these would be kind of fun more
my projections have it would be kind of
fun character yeah my spreadsheet has
the 18 to one
oh you're scratchy okay my algorithm has
to be 18 to 1.
an algorithm written algorithm
[Laughter]
in between the lines look i've i'm on
the lakers first quarter money line
and you know what if you don't want to
eat that kind of juice you can take a
minus two and a half just so you're
fading kelly
the lakers are winning this game they're
coming out hot kelly
you didn't look happy with me i'm sorry
i'm just taking the lakers to
to have it god i'm so glad you're about
to be gone soon see you later
what what i don't know can we just kick
burnout now forever
just permanently kick him out nobody
ever has to see him again right because
this game the series is not going seven
games it is not going seven games
i hope it goes seven i want to be right
here next tuesday
with everyone giving hoodies away having
fun having a party in the br app i'm
rooting for seven games that's all
no i want to be sitting in my backyard
sipping on
something that's close enough to
hennessy why am i enjoying my life
instead of hanging out with you guys
close to nothing
i don't know i was thinking of something
close i couldn't think of alcohol off
the top of my head
fine mikey locks special lime white claw
done little tito's floater on top
greg what are the things give
someone a hoodie
the doctor he's rocking with cabbie
lakers come out fast first to ten i'm
fading you
but since i'm in a given mood call me
gregor claus i'm giving you a hoodie
uh here we go uh to the funk doctor
shout out to the funk doctor here we go
um
mets are mediocre he's back he says greg
get spicy king my hoodie from the vern
comment
yes that was a fire burn comment so i'm
going to give spicy king a hoodie
uh mikey mikey the people want you in
the comments mikey
the people want you in the comments
jumping
that's all i ask mikey i know they miss
you
and i i was going to surprise you with
this but i want you to just
jump in there and give away some hoodies
because the
the people they miss you mike oh my god
greg
well mike reading while mike is reading
he's just over there gloating look at
the smile on his face
he's just like sitting there keeping it
to himself like mike's the best
he's so good these are my burners
adulation take what we're betting though
while you're doing that while you're
looking for what we're being burned
while i'm being burned someone pick a
bet
from the comments
mikey all right all right all right all
right i'm gonna do it do you have it
you guys are fine i'm trying to pass the
torch here
everybody just loves mikey all it is is
mikey
race 210. kelly gonna get a note for the
alcohol
get her my name does not have two e's we
are hiding
greg our boy the people's champ and i'll
see you on ig live tonight
craig we're gonna hit race 10 i love it
what's up i'm gonna get back in the
comments yes yes yes
i disagree i saw a lot of court one
first quarter comments in here mike
oh that was i think you're in a
different stream mikey
i just wanted to talk about how you just
froze when we asked you to read comments
you totally froze
that silence you were trying to get
mikey was not ready
you guys told me to look at this
all right while mikey is reading more
comments i'm gonna get into what we
taught you mikey if you see any good
ones
just start yelling okay what we taught
you today
iggy is not winning mvp greg iggy is not
winning mvp
do not press that bet please please for
the love of your bank account
number two send us screenshots of your
same game
parlay tickets or of your close
l's your big big parlay w's we want it
all
we are hammering the heat
tinny as our game four quick hitter i
kind of hate that
but we're hammering it as a family me
too yeah
and check out our ig stories tonight
kevin iron lockstep
for that and more first quarter quick
hitters with
br underscore greg triple g's
in the odds of us having a game seven
show
next tuesday are plus 450 on fanduel
so you can take that one we'll see
plus like 9.50 what are you talking
about
vern looks like he spends his weekends
dominating kids at the go-kart track
that's a sick burning
yeah i dominate them i dominate
all right if you want a hoodie today we
will dm you but for now
we're leaving the chat peace
peace
[Music]
you